- In addition to
Black Lives Matter,
there's also a movement for
Black trans lives matter.
- Yes.
- Could you talk a little about that?
- Yeah, you know,
I got a lot of heat.
I did a message to America on my
Instagram,
and I got a lotta heat for
calling Black people out.
The relationship that the
African-American community has
with the LGBTQ+ community,
it is
not good,
and trans women,
specifically Black trans women,
trans women of color,
are dying at the hands of cis Black men
at alarming rates.
- Wow.
- And what I'm saying is,
it's a simple do unto others metaphor,
right.
- Mhm.
- We want somebody to stop killin' us,
we have to make sure that
we have our house in order.
- Mhm.
- Period.
And it's a conversation
that pose presents,
it's an uncomfortable conversation.
You know, because
trans lives
are the next on the list
of dismissible humans.
Trans people are human beings,
I'm a gay man,
but I'm a Black man first,
and until Black people understand that,
we're gonna be in the quagmire
goin' round and round.
You can't expect
somebody else to change,
until we can look at ourselves,
and make that transformation
within ourselves.
- I mean I think that's,
that's applicable to
all of us.
- Yes.
- You know, even in whatever
your situation is in life,
and whatever you're going through in your
personal hurdles, and challenges,
like I think you know,
you can't expect others to do that
unless you're willing to do it yourself.
- Correct.
- And really take a look in that mirror,
so I think,
I think that it's amazing
that you're standing up for everyone.